former energy secretary texas governor
rick perry
along with fox news contributor and
speaker of the house newt gingrich
uh governor perry i'll start with you
because this was
something you and newt gingrich felt
very strongly about
how important how impactful is this to
the 17 states
that are in question tonight well you
got 45
of the gasoline that's going to uh the
eastern part of the united states going
through that pipeline so it's
you know this is a national security
issue but sean here's
the really important thing for me from
the standpoint of uh
we matter of fact i'm pretty sure the
clinton administration
bush administration the obama
administration all worked to get america
to be independent of other countries of
oil and gas and we did that under the
trump administration
we not only became independent we became
dominant
and this administration wants to take
that away stop building pipelines
well if there was ever a wake up called
hate
uh president biden maybe we should
build more pipelines instead of shutting
them down
this was it today with the colonial
pipeline
this is insanity well let's also let's
not forget with the stroke of a pen
executive fiat these are high paying
career jobs in the energy sector
and for the first time in 75 years
america became
energy independent great for national
security
great for career jobs for american
citizens
mr speaker we now have it looks like
this attack came from russia
then we have an unholy alliance between
the chinese the russians and the
iranians
fighting a proxy war against the the
middle east
basically in total especially israel and
israel is under fire tonight
i don't see joe biden funding the
palestinians and getting back in the
iranian deal having any positive effect
yeah and when you think about it this is
real
hang on newt gingrich go ahead good i'm
sorry okay
i'm just going to say of course governor
perry knows much more than i do
about the pipeline part of this but on
the national security part let me just
say
uh we ought to pass a law immediately
that makes it this
this kind of hacking subject to a death
penalty
and the law should include a provision
that the president
through a judicial process should be
able to order the killing
of anybody overseas who's doing this i
mean we have now spent like 15
years on defense uh we have no idea who
they are
we have no idea where they are and if we
didn't know who they were we'd have no
mechanism
to do anything about it a a great
country
cannot allow people to come in and
savage it
have no consequences and then wait for
the next attack
and yet that literally is where we are
right now i think this ought to be a
bipartisan issue
and people ask themselves what are we
prepared to do to protect america
from whether it's official governments
or whether it is
private citizens this is an intolerable
situation
how does he get to bipartisanship when
it comes to funding the iranian muellers
and getting into a deal where you don't
have any place anytime inspections
how do you get into a deal when the
chinese and the russians
are giving iranians weapons for their
proxy war against yemen
and the three countries aligned against
uh the united states and its allies newt
well it's pretty straightforward you get
a week or two and again governor perry
can explain this in much more technical
detail than i can
you get two or three weeks of the
northeast
losing 45 percent of its oil and gas
and the american people are going to say
enough of this
uh baloney we want this country
protected
we want it to be effective we want it to
be immediate
and we're going to fire anybody who
doesn't get in line
people are not going to tolerate these
kind of
which i'm told are constant but these
kind of attacks which are a new kind of
warfare
and i don't care if they're private
criminals or they're public criminals
it's a it's an act of war against the
united states to do stuff like this
we need to react to it as an act of war
and the american people are going to
look at their representatives
and their senators and they're going to
say you don't fix this
your successor will because i am i'm not
going to put up with it
and i'm not going to put up with you if
you don't fix it
governor perry it's sort of like
corporations don't pay taxes
they're not going to lower their bottom
line they will they will pass them on to
we the consumer
okay joe biden has his new green deal
agenda
it's really a socialist agenda that
means that
we're now energy dependent the lifeblood
of the world's economy that hasn't
changed overnight
and now we'll be dependent again and
that means every single consumer item
that is trucked in
to whatever store it happens to be won't
it be the consumers that are paying the
higher costs for fuel
and now would even go higher
get ready for the inflation that's going
to come with this
and you know when i when i look over at
uh
north carolina i think about a
democratic governor over there that
declared a state of emergency
think about the state of new mexico that
is
absolutely going to be devastated
because of the fossil fuel decisions
that are being made in the current
administration
you gotta demo well i think everybody in
new mexico is a democrat elected
official now two
united states senators and the governor
and the secretary of interiors from new
mexico
and they're willing to throw their state
uh into the into the toilet so to speak
uh to support this administration i
don't understand that i don't understand
how people think that their political
affiliation is more important than the
people that they represent
and so you know
newt is absolutely correct i mean the
speaker nails this
when he talks about this being such an
important national security
issue not only is it the economic side
of a lot of
people in states and union workers and
what have you
but when you think about who's this
really helping
well it's helping the chinese because
the administration wants to
do away with american fossil fuels and
rely
totally upon the renewable side of
things and a
part of your portfolio being renewable
makes sense
but to see the way they're moving away
from everything that has to do with
fossil fuel
this green new deal insanity that we're
seeing
them uh stand up with and the people
that this helps
is china china i think sixty percent of
the solar panels come from china
eighty percent of the poly silicon that
they use in that
industry is in china's hands so the idea
that we're you know this is
we got to address this and and the
speaker is right it's going to take some
drastic
measures we need to send a clear and
powerful message
you come into the united states and you
attack us
using cyber methods we will come
and get you we will find you and you
will pay a huge and heavy price
until we do that it's free game
all right governor secretary perry
speaker gingrich thank you both hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else